irgendwas passiert kohle gefunden zehn
minuten mitmachen 30 minuten
ja ich musste ganz vielen cut machen
also sehen wir uns gleich in einer
sekunde macht gut bist an bleibt geil
gemacht ja manchmal diesmal an seine
gehabt ganz einfach anfangen wenn du
bist ja da
21 a la und seien herzlich willkommen zu
einer weiteren folge immer mit dem coni
wir schein kraft
die gruppen den gar nicht den stein nur
freunde macht ihr aufgefallen ist ich
habe ganz viel leben in einem fluss
gefunden muss deswegen gar nicht märz
dieses umweg gehen mit diesen ganzen
posterstein kram scheiße penis aber ich
sag mal so dass jedes vierte biest man
muss den umweg nicht gehen man kann auch
ganz normal auf minecraft klassisch
fahren aber das ist hier ja also ich
könnte natürlich auch pflasterstein
alles bla bla bla bla bla aber ich kann
auch einfach den leben hier raus nehmen
direkt von daher das geht schneller
ich fliege jetzt gleich wieder zurück da
vorne zu den sparern und versuchte
einfach nur nonstop zu metzeln ganze
folge gleich minuten an noch gemerkt da
muss ich irgendwie selbst motivieren
ich möchte dir gerne eine home tour
bereiten wenn man haus fertig ist mein
ding star jeff beck ist ja auch egal
dass die fassade schon mal genauer hin
du bildest dir ein ich weiß wer ist
dieser turm alter seine ölquelle größer
als ein baum
deswegen steht ihr die fackel riesig
wow hab ich noch nicht erlebt
dort habe ich noch nicht erlebt jetzt
lädt sich mal wieder auf sonnenaufgang
alles dreht sich wieder auf für mich
gehört ich bekomme heute abend von simon
die sachen zurück das richtig happy da
bin ich viel verloren
ich bin erstmal diesen batzen dann
geht's ab kiste sortieren muss bald auch
egal hauptsache bietet euch ich bin ja
gar nicht amüsiert wenn ich einfach ist
wie das vivaz alters diese diese cave
spiders die gruppen lassen
was denn das land ist dass selbst bei
dass tropfen ja trocken ja fast jedes
mal allerdings das abonnierte gold und
viermal haben den dienst arge jobkomm
steine scherben
wo gibt's spiders ja ich bin allerdings
sind diesem turm 30 nicht meine oder
business case paar ist das normal ist
abgebaut
ich brauche 8 x 8 64 werden
ich glaube doch was kann ich aus kies
machen nichts fast nix ich sage ich so
viel kies feuerstein so viel kies gib
mir ich brauche das
nee ich bleib platzieren der ruine ich
muss irgendwie abdunkeln aber tabu
kirsten block der nicht unter fällt kaum
ich frage mich was ich brauche acht
deswegen hofft acht stücke nur komm
schon das muss reichen
er hat kommt schon ich gebe mir echt
mühe gaben das könnte auch mal belohnt
werden finde ich dass wir oben durch
eine pfütze richtig machen
achso und mozy stein oder dem oster
steinmann so unter snobs sagt ist sehr
gut zum vater war er fantastisch element
bietet was sonst kein anderer
natürlicher blog bietet wie was jetzt
most arena dann überlegen ob ich mir
jetzt ich bin gerade am dom bisschen an
ich weiß nicht was ich zuerst was machen
soll
was steht zur auswahl jack and that back
oder mein haus weiterbauen
ich brauche einfach echt eine menge
leben
sie verstehe ich jetzt nichts kommt hier
ist alles düster
die ganze kacke grad zu das muss doch
reichen
irgendwas passiert
so ich habe es noch moment meine frau
brauchbar
bedeutet superstaat
denn so kann ich aber mitnehmen
kräfte bis noch da naja ich bin ja nur
topscorer so gebaut hast die viecher die
ganze zeit im visier hoch fliegen
ganze zeit voll mich
so zeigt fall runter weil wir nämlich
oben in einer kannte so stehen und die
einfach zu schnetzeln wie es sich gehört
optimal war richtig gut wie nie um
steine jallohs kohleabbau richtig
gestalten
apollos weiter
monaten noch ein bisschen lauter
haha devise spyder alter ich flechsig
weg glaubt man dran reiße mir den arsch
auf und du bleibst mit alba an der die
von ihm gedacht aber nicht von der
spider alter mann kriegt ja übels viel
erfahrung wenn man die ganze kohle
abbaut
aber jetzt trocken die nicht mehr so gut
wie am feuer so schön gejobbt
und das auch noch so krass viel kohle
einfach
ja also es ja auch noch cool
es ist tatsächlich einfach 12
vielleicht nicht einfach zu geil diese
welt
ein wort und ich versetze den ich habe
ein blogger cap du musst dir jetzt
konzentrieren du hast ein block gehen
richtig setzen so darf man gar nicht
erst anfangen
wie scheiße ich hier die damals ab und
ich ganz viel schaden den ich gut finde
history müssten wir nicht wirklich gar
nicht brauche schneebälle das ist dass
hier viele wildtiere leben kaktus als
wenn ich oben ganz kurz war die job doch
fantastisch all das hätte ich nicht
gedacht jetzt die die kef spiders ja
also ich habe jetzt schon zehn millionen
scheiben und ich stehe hier sind zwei
bonner ich lass dir auch weiter spawn
ich bin nur kurz mal alle anderen ebenen
aus richtig ich habe richtig viel leben
wieder
also ich finde ich ja auch immer so was
wie eine uhr oder sowas in den kisten
uhr das frauen- und gar nicht nur
glamour volland ich kenne jetzt schon
wieder ne wurst damit das unnötigste
wasser gibt in minecraft fällig
ihr hört nichts gegen die fliegenden
rächer schluss dass von allen seiten
klicks geboten war
sodann ist hier noch leben die nicht
mehr und jetzt wird gleich dunkel wird
dann wird das richtig frech glaube ich
möchte eine fackel ich möchte holz um
holz und spielt eine million scheibe
geklopft ist richtig stark
ich kann ich auch wirklich am tag fahren
dass einige fantastisch hier habe ich
holz bitte kein roboter ich hasse dich
ja schon die allee you find ich richtig
viel leben ich bin schon wieder wirklich
nachgeschossen davon chaco freunde ich
habe noch kein mal diamanten gefunden
aber ich hab mir schon nicht hergestellt
ich habe noch nie jemanden gefunden hier
noch nie noch nie was nun gesucht wohin
also ich bin jetzt nicht so ein typ der
einfach für 16 geht und dann sich
dadurch gerät aber ich glaube ich mal
meine meinung teilte bald mit seinem
programm das die halt so was wie es
eigentlich sein programm code dafür
keiner hätte nicht benutzt einfach strip
man irgendwas man glaube ich also stand
im wiki glaube ich bin ein echter
experte davon so ich will jetzt jetzt
soll ich hab genug leben
ich habe ist sechseinhalb sexleben
ich muss
du musst was
crowe auf die flattr mache das einzige
was wirklich nervig ist sind hier
gleichen teile laces diese noch stark
die waren richtig wie schaden würde auch
verbrennen dass es voll nervös wenn ihr
verbrennt jetzt wird dunkel das heißt
ich stelle mal ein paar verbringt ein
test es fragt was das was bringt hat das
hätte expert.de da hab ich meiner habe
ich mit rechts drauf gemacht
dann steht da nimm deine hand weg sie
hätte abgeschnitten werden können das
gehirn experte steht nimm deine hand weg
sie hat abgeschnitten werden können hat
aber schon selber geschrieben ich werde
mit nein das ist halt vom steht an unten
links sowie you can only built 90 brände
zu viele gegner
julia kaffeetassen gewitter war das lied
die termine im scherben hast jetzt 12
ich kann mir gar zu erbetteln gegen zehn
places oder so gleichzeitig bremst
jedoch immer mehr
komm ran junge kaum ran klatschte auf
den tresen heute nicht sonst gehe
darf ich hier mein eigen sind ich nehme
meinen eigenen land und das schöne ist
ich kriege ja auch nebenbei blaze
gewarnt und level spieler level 30
obendrauf
irgendwie so geht das kennst du das
nicht kann ich nicht geschockt
ich bin einfach nur gerade dass es so
langweilig muss die ganze zeit auf meine
mails raider draufdrücken dass sie mir
mal ein sand rausnehmen
ist das langweilig kleines biest alter
aber wenigstens die schöne minimum
schreiben raus
größte reise wollen bauen und ich habe
31 level besitzer
kann ich mit nanosilber für die nanos
selber vermutlich kann man das auch
fahrzeuge wurden auf shared 15
die kann man nicht so vertrauen sowieso
nicht ganz alle sachen nur in büchern
aber zaubern
ja stimmt 15 minuten schon die hälfte es
geschafft fast halbzeit recht
ungemütlich